tablet der steht die ganze zeit auf mich
drauf ich glaube der realisiert nicht
dass hier in schutz gibt sie
fertigmachen h4 opfer
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
concha simon braucht wie immer jahre für
seinen ganzen programme die zu starten
und wir spielen meint es geht sofort los
ja allerdings bevor sie man jetzt dass
da kein muster einer ganz kurzen was
anderes sagen und zwei ich hab ich schon
sachen das mit meiner website das haben
eine alle mitbekommen die mich bei
facebook ist dorfen und abonniert haben
oder wie das heißt
und zwar war das nur ein aprilscherz das
heißt meine website wurde nicht gehackt
ich habe die ganzen website nur neu
aufgebaut und dementsprechend braucht
ihr euch jetzt gar keine sorgen machen
wenn ihr einfach mal auf dem es zu
verbessern wollte das ist jetzt mein
neuer blog dass ein fachkräfte punkt de
steht auch in der beschreibung und jetzt
geht es dann auch los also erst mal ganz
kurz noch nicht werden
ja und ich bin dann auch im livestream
nebenbei ist vielleicht ab und zu mal
was dazu auch zu vielleicht mal sagen
toni kraft hatte ich werd ich später bei
der strategie komplett adresse in
battlefield toll mein gott
was trägt das okay gut warte ich bin
dunkelblau
das heißt ich bin mit meiner ex frau und
ich bin gegen mich auch okay ich bin
hellblau beispielsweise die welt hier
ich wollte sagen olaf schnell passiert
real ist bei mir schon ein getöteter
mach kaputt waren kaputt mein job so
kaputt machen anke rezmer leben gerettet
ok conny wohl wie sieht es bei dir aus
ich töte creole nein creole lauf ich hab
glaub ich hab ja ich bin tot
das habe ich dem os x gekillt jetzt will
ich hier den noch wohler wenn du tot
bist oder das ist bei uns umlagert
rechnet hätten nicht alle fertig wir
machen sie fertig die runde ist damit im
live stream
doch der konnte live stream diese
spricht so aber er zögert ich sag's
einfach nur so weil wir ja auf leben so
ja gut
pressearbeit ein team anfeuern los team
ich kenne hier keinen mit dem ich gerade
spiele aber ich habe schon drei kills
nein wieder vom dach aus abhilfe ach ja
auch falsch ist meine stimme bemerkt
habt warum die zukunft führt ich bin
auch sehr heiser aber ich habe mich auch
wieder face kemmann hier habe ich noch
gar nicht angeguckt hey ich versuche
jetzt erstmal den simon zu töten
da kommt ja so wie es eventuell sehen
können aber ich glaube der fans kam die
man das nicht zurück ich habe auch gar
kein richtiges schwert sein kein stein
schwer ohne folgen
gegen wen stein schwert darf man ja man
ja mal jemand gibt sachen europa so mir
gib mir ein schwert gegen schwere danke
danke danke danke du bist cool bleibt
zusammen
okay leute jetzt auch wenn wir konnten
nicht besiegen der stoff saugt lacht
wirken
ich werde abgeschossen ich einmal noch
darauf dass die chancen hier machtlos
war es die gold ihm fertig hier
was für ein durchschnittliches weismain
wahrheit also mir gefällt dass das spiel
eigentlich noch besser als damals weil
es tatsächlich viel geld eigentlich
mittlerweile auch mehr als trockene
meinung etwa meine geht doch momentan
gar nicht dabei also echt cool also aus
der man hier auf die beine gestellt
coole sache nein ich bin schon immer tun
was die firma metzel abgeht
der fall der mitte geht es einmal
richtig ab ach scheiße drauf auf jeden
fall ein panzer oder einstein schwert
ein panzer panzer recht gut brustpanzer
weil ich so ich muss jetzt leider mal
ein bisschen bin ich bin gestorben
gestorben steinwerth stellen
schwerdt alte autokraten geht's ab ja
danke danke nur oder online ich will
keine schläge bekommen wo es bald hier
muss mein team ok hat kann mir einer von
welchen stein schwert geben die höheren
mich zwar nicht aber kann das einer von
euch lasst ohligs entwickler getötet ja
es hat gerade jemand geschrieben niemand
erwähnt neulich hab nur gesagt schönes
ding wohl alle gäste sind wieder da ja
man ja mama wohl aber an ohlig auch
respekt an honig auf jeden fall weil nur
lecker stent entwickelt also mojang hat
entscheiden bei die idee entwickelt so
was okay lahnstein schwert also probst
an die beiden goals komplett raus nur
unsere dienstag auch noch ihr habt ihr
nicht in gold ist raus ich bin hellblau
ach so ich bin der tod bleibt zusammen
team love dann noch ein leben übrig
darunter vier leben ja okay du fliegen
jetzt endlich warum zu laufen geschaffen
dass nicht mehr leute es schaffen dass
das letzte jahr ist ja nein ja wir
schaffen das sagt knapp das war knapp
nice gemacht aber du bist verlauf
gestorben oder richtig auf gestorben ich
habe unser team nicht gerade zum sieg
geführt aber auch noch einer der pvp
proalter dass gläubiger wohl mit der
google trio mio ok soll runden
dranhängen ja dann will ich würd sagen
einfach wieder auf 1 startet dann gerade
wieder neu entbrannt wie sehr uns dann
gleich wieder aufnehmen weiter auf
angreifer beitreten wartet erstattet
doch jetzt jeden moment nur
obwohl nicht ob ich nicht doch raus
müssen jetzt nur auf den servern mit
offenem ohr ja man kann darauf kann ich
einfach jetzt so weiter sprechen
du kannst einfach so thurk 12 okay da
sind wir zurück bei mein wort gespielt
so verpackt wie man das ein bisschen
zuviel spaghetti gefressen bis hin zu
fenster gelöscht
und da ist einsamer tod derart ich bin
mit hoffentlich der meister ja
interessant die das nicht gut doch
klappt sehr gut
henry das entwickelt hat das hat doch
nichts das spiel auf jeden tag oder so
dass sie selbst einmal als spätester
wird man egal ich bin auch ohne das
ganze spiel über der profi ich hab nicht
mal den ersten jump wollen mich
verarschen und jumper weiterkommt er
guckt wo ich bin
bisher kann man schon kommen dass ich
bin auf der leiter gefallen fünf
sekunden haben noch die mama ich hab
fast gewonnen aber das trio de einsamer
tod um gespielt und ich mitspielen
heisters
ich bin was bin ich ja nicht alle
youtuber sind da sondern dass irgendwer
in einem team ist halt zusammen
wir sind nicht zusammen mit einsamer tod
ich bin mit barcelona immer noch mit
mailworx und passt dazu geht die gute
musik an
ich habe irgendwie keine kiste bekommen
weil ich total verwirrt ich habe mit
kissen mit panzern und natürlich direkt
angezogen leute werfen mein schwert
bitte vor die füße was bin ich für die
farbe um gespielt und viel blau kolleg
und und entsalzen meinem team erst wird
sage ich habe die runde gewonnen oder
ich gewinnen das spiel das so leute wir
schaffen das nix sehr blöd es gibt noch
diesen schutz als shop mit b ok passend
die spannende musik hat regal von tablet
der steht die ganze zeit auf mich drauf
ich glaube der realisiert nicht dass
hier in schutz gibt stefano liegt bei
dir ich werde dir vorsichtig da wie man
den schatten geworfen
danke schön und es zieht ihn
fertigmachen h4 opfer das schlägt die
hand hat ob ich drauf dazu würde ich den
weg an einem pfeiler rücken bekommt das
geht wieder die musik passt richtig gut
zum spiel das team 369 und schon wieder
ein freier rücken bekommen zweimal
wollte schlechter kommt man auf eine
zweite leck baust du dreimal freund dass
wir dann falls sie geschossen
blitzschläge lunge durch die schläge des
lebens flughafen luqa schuss 8 die
topografie ich bin auch jetzt schon wow
gespielt
er hat auch ein wow account okay du hast
was du hast 5 watt power points eltern
kannst das kauflisten so wie es
weitergeht wie geht das zb
hilfe hilfe hilfe hilfe ich bin noch weg
und wenn ich jetzt / b gedrückt habe
muss man das inventar ziehen oder wie
habe ich das dann warum reden wir alle
helfer wie ich habe jetzt auch diese
maschinenpistole gedrückt wie kann ich
jetzt auswählen
ich hab keine ahnung maschinenpistole
redest du jetzt ja keine ahnung ich hab
das spiel so selten spielt schreibt mir
das mal bitte in die kommentare wenn ihr
wisst wie das geht ich habe dieses die
kinder ausgewählt euro ich habe getötet
habe zwar keinen plan wie ich die ganzen
dingsda ab feuer
die ganzen schlüsselblume
mein gott wusstet ihr schon dass sich
die wogen profi bin
was lady akku betroffen getroffen
auch conti wie sie sollte nur fallen
sich merck schon bin einfach viel besser
als du schlecht aber wenn ich dann mal
besser wenn er nutzt das von aus harry
oder komm hoch
orio ist auch gute pvp ich habe schon
zwei getötet props andriola barlow habe
ich direkt wieder stehen klasse tiroler
super ich bin team blau
was ist denn da mal wir sind hellblau
themen wie bist du hast bis 4 mit acht
leben ich weiß auch dass weder mann tot
zusammen das wird knapp
junge wie camp mir einfach zu dritt auf
seinem berg rauf wie geil ist das denn
bitte
uns kann keiner ran außerdem schießen
fall aber dazu sind irgendwie zu blöd
heiße
die dann auch noch in unserem team
bleibt zusammen
jan füllemann arztes gestorben
alter alle sterben die ihr hochkommen
alter sind das kanu bist krank noch
immer da oben die das junge team goldes
viele übels viele freuen sie wollten ist
raus nicht wer da hoch
ich werde auch nicht will auch normal
dass nicht genug punkte bleibt hier
unten im alter wie so viele leute hier
oben wie gelindert
wir gewinnen gegen team um gespielt nein
wir dürfen nicht gegen conny verlieren
nur noch zwei leben bleibt hier
wenn wir gewinnen scheiße japaner leben
dennoch zwei leben und konnte ihren 56
ja und wir gehen jetzt auf euch drauf
also ich schätze bleibt hier oder auch
zwei leben bleibt hier bleiben ein leben
mit ja 21 erschwert nein jahres ja das
klappt jetzt noch ein leben ich habe
jeden gespielt gewonnen er ist jetzt der
profi ran
ich bin okay jetzt sagen wir beide eine
runde gewonnen
ist doch auf jeden fall cool gelaufen ja
wenn es euch gefallen hat lasst uns wert
da schreibt einfach die kommentare
andere spielmodi dir vor ort versuchen
ihr könnt den spielmodi kommentare
schreiben
dann geht es bei dieser und pvc schaum
weiter bis dieses große mega neue
projekt anfängt oder eventuell können
wir die runden die wir dann nachher
zusammen machen auch um komplikationen
wenn ihr wollt dass die unseren
spielshow bestehen bleibt hat der andere
konnte ich meine wie möglich um computer
also das sieht man auch daran dass ich
mal nachrichten bekommen hey wo bleibt
die unkompliziert auch wollt ja deutlich
muss in einer sache noch sozusagen als
nicht so einfach immer die aufzunehmen
weil pvp es halt nicht so wie nur normal
ist es einfach aufnehmen kann er
gelassen und dann hochlädt erlebt
manchmal ist einfach schwierig zusammen
so ein termin zu finden und manchmal
auch schwierig dann rechtzeitig als
machen also neues nur ist eine richtzeit
2 915 wird 1920 dann bitte nicht ans
bein fließen und suchen wir bitte doch
das qualifiziert ist
wenn mal ein tag keine computer kommt
hat mir einfach stress oder so ist china
auch neben jeden tag durch sie schon
einander stress sondern dass die man
einfach mal gepennt hat oder dass
niemand schläft und ich bin da und da
und geht allerdings trabis wir legten
uns das buch auch am router automatisch
angehalten dass er perfekt jetzt gerade
zum ende
also ich würde das kind weg na ja aber
egal ist jetzt vorbei ok wenn es euch
gefallen hat daumen hoch geben wenn ihr
mehr unkompliziert können uns einfach
spielmodi in die kommentare schreiben
und dann sehen uns beim nächsten mal von
meiner seite aus